[Music]
when i knit i feel calm i
tell myself everything you all the energy goes into the
ground the energy that is stagnant and i
relax and i feel good my name
is dominique keller schweitzer i
am known in  as an artist like
adam tricot I'm a medical doctor
psychiatrist and my secondary profession
let's say it's knitting I made an
amalgam of everything and I do
psychiatry knit tent
[Music]
so I discovered knitting horn and
children around the age of 7-8 years old to
grandma taught me how to knit the basics
all my life i knitted but i
knitted the classic way
knitting shawls sweaters things
like that until  the year 2011 when i
suddenly decided to do
things in three dimensions the first
thing i knit was a
fish
i showed her beware my fish she
tells me but now you  see that you're making
a chicken so I had to be fine
I'm going to make a chicken and I continued
[Music]
I have been practicing psychiatry since 2001
before I was a general practitioner and
I specialized in traumatology
that's when I realized
that knitting could help in
psychiatry
because when you have had a trauma
you disconnect the two  parts of the
brain and to reconnect
it takes repetitive movements on
both sides to coordinate
with the knitting you have two needles
and you always do the same
repetitive movement and it's as
if you're removing the side between the two
hemispheres
and that's  is very effective in treating
trauma
[Music]
I have already harvested everything I have knitted a
butcher's shop a delicatessen a pastry shop
a cheese shop I have knitted human heads
anatomical parts to the
winner a heart which was
anatomically correct in Switzerland I am
at the blues or horse jumping thomas
zurich
these two museums of modern art and
technology and design where I have a fridge
full of food  especially
pork and fine meat and
rice sausages things very nice to look at
in general the reactions are very
positive people smile
vague humor I say yes why I do this
the answer is because it makes me
happy
I  I like it I love it
[Music]